with me now former US Attorney Jody
Jennifer and Governor Mike Huckabee
former presidential candidate Fox News
contributor you did a great job filling
it thank you
great to see you alright gov we heard
from Hillary Clinton tonight yeah for
going on and on and on already
predicting Trump's gonna win basically
and trying to do legitimize a Trump
reelection tonight but the Democrats
seem to have this problem with the word
spying still I want to play something
for you this is various cable networks
around April 10th let's watch this FISA
warrant - to surveil to spy on Carter
page is in October 2016 the application
to spy on Carter page was 50 pages long
when they spied on former Trump campaign
adviser Carter paid the application
despite on page was approved by the
president's own Deputy Attorney General
yeah so last April they had no problem
with calling it's fine but now I was
like how dare you use the word spying
and I thought Barr did a masterful job
of the spelling out exactly what that
meant going back to his own background
but the bigger problem for the Democrats
is they got nothing they got nothing
they're like people who show up at the
barbecue restaurant at closing time and
all the meat is gone
so what they're left to do is just lick
the bones gnaw on them a little bit and
suck the barbecue sauce out of the
bottle they've got nothing else to do
and I think in a way I almost felt sorry
for him watching them but then I didn't
because they were so rude and
disrespectful of the Attorney General
and how he maintained his composure I'm
like I didn't crawl across the table and
go after a few of them is a testament to
diplomacy grace and being a gentleman
yeah a true professional Joe they're
making a big deal tonight about the fact
that Barr said on the house testimony
tomorrow because they're gonna have say
we're going to have staff attorneys ask
some of the questions for our viewers
out there why is it a problem if some
staff attorneys ask questions of the
Attorney General that I mean the stuff
you see online people send can't take
the heat can't take some questions from
some staff attorneys big deal
no actually it's just not protocol it's
just not done to a senate-confirmed
cabinet member they are supposed to be
questioned by the members
the committee and it seems according to
chairman Nadler that none of the
Democratic members is capable of asking
the Attorney General proper questions
that's a surprise to me since many of
them are lawyers but the only time you
allow counsel to interview witnesses in
a hearing is when it's an investigative
hearing when it's almost like a grand
jury you never do that for oversight
hearings or budget hearings or anything
so and remember bill Barr agreed to
appear and then after he agreed
Nataly decided to change the rules it's
just typical Democratic you're hiding
dirty pool oh sure it sure it means just
governor now disgrace FBI director Jim
Comey Joe's favorite people now he's the
man who led the charge for all these
corrupt antitrump agents he's again in
the process of blame-shifting writing in
a New York Times op-ed just came out mr.
Trump eats your soul in small bites mr.
Trump makes everyone a co-conspirator to
his preferred set of facts or delusions
well the lack of professional
responsibility from this man is stunning
well first of all he's dead wrong about
Donald Trump Donald Trump does not eat
people sold in small bites he takes it
one great big chomp and he's over and
he's done with it it's one of the
reasons that he's president because he
does know how to take on an adversary
Jim Comey has a lot of splainin to do
how he leaked how he lied your bar he's
investigate he's gonna be investigating
I don't revenge but I want justice I
really am NOT interested in just okay
they did this to us let's do it to them
I'm interested in justice for one reason
if the most powerful arm of the federal
government can go after and almost take
down a sitting president what on God's
earth could they do regular me James
Comey Brannon America's dirt prop James
Comey America's dirty cop ate the soul
of the FBI he destroyed the FBI and this
little piece of paper which is the FISA
Court ruling from 2017 where the chief
judge outlines four
four years of lying by the Obama FBI and
Justice Department to the court about
illegal spying by three contractors is
going to be their undoing and the court
has already informed the Justice
Department of the extent of the lying by
the Obama FBI and DOJ you know what
Comey can write poetry and go stand in
the forests and redwoods I don't you
know whatever you know this goofy guy he
better get used to it because this is
gonna be his undoing this little show to
hold up a prop and point at me when you
hold up a prop and it's like a Pfizer
forget it but they're they're already
trying to spin these investigations of
their conduct are they not absolutely
that's what this is about they know
they're on the griddle they're on the
griddle now all these guys it's the
Brennan clapper griddle I mean they just
then they they are fighting back the
only way they know how dirty all right
guys great to see both of you thank you
and thanks for mentioning the barbecue
Arkansas is always going to go back to
barbecue these guys my god